[Música]
Imagine un grupo de personas qué tamaño
cree que tendría que tener el grupo para
tener más de un 50% de probabilidad de
que dos personas en el cumplan años el
mismo día supongamos que no hay gemelos
que cada cumpleaños es Igualmente
probable e ignoremos los años bisiestos
Tómese un momento para pensarlo
la respuesta puede parecer baja en un
grupo de 23 personas hay un 50,73% de
probabilidad de que dos personas cumplan
años el mismo día pero con 365 días en
un año cómo es posible que se necesite
un grupo tan pequeño para obtener
siquiera la probabilidad de cumpleaños
compartido Por qué nos falla la
intuición
para averiguarlo veamos como un
matemático calcularía las probabilidades
de un cumpleaños el mismo día
podemos utilizar un campo de las
Matemáticas conocido como combinatorias
que se ocupa de las probabilidades de
combinaciones diferentes
lo primero es dar vuelta el problema
tratar de calcular las probabilidades de
una coincidencia es un reto porque hay
muchas formas de hacer coincidir un
cumpleaños en un grupo
En cambio es más fácil calcular la
probabilidad de que el cumpleaños de
todo sea diferente
Cómo ayuda Esto o hay una coincidencia
de cumpleaños en el grupo o no la hay
así que las probabilidades de coincidir
y las de que no coincidan deben sumar
100% entonces podemos hallar la
probabilidad de coincidencia restando la
de no coincidencia desde 100
para calcular las probabilidades de no
coincidencia empiece en pequeño calcule
la probabilidad de que solo un par de
personas tengan cumpleaños diferentes un
día del año será el cumpleaños de la
persona a lo que deja 364 posibles
cumpleaños para la persona B
la probabilidad de diferentes cumpleaños
para a y b es de 364 de 365 un 0,997 o
99,7%, bastante alta añada a la persona
c la probabilidad de que ella tenga un
cumpleaños único en este grupo es de 363
sobre 365 porque hay dos fechas de
nacimiento ya ocupadas por a y b
las probabilidades de D serán de 362
sobre 365 y así hasta que las de W de
343 sobre 365
multiplique todos estos datos juntos y
obtendrá la probabilidad de que nadie
coincida en un cumpleaños esto da
0,4927 entonces hay un
49,27% de probabilidad de que nadie en
el grupo de 23 comparta un cumpleaños
cuando restamos eso a 100 hay un 50,73%
de probabilidad de al menos una
coincidencia más incluso que las no
coincidencias
la clave para una probabilidad tan alta
de coincidencia en un grupo pequeño es
el número sorprendentemente grande de
pares posibles si un grupo crece el
número de combinaciones posibles aumenta
mucho más rápidamente
un grupo de cinco personas tiene 10
pares posibles y cada una puede
emparejarse con cualquiera de las otras
cuatro la mitad de esas combinaciones
son redundantes porque emparejar a con
la B es igual que emparejar B con a así
que dividimos por 2 Bajo el mismo
razonamiento un grupo de 10 personas
tiene 45 parejas y un grupo de 23 tiene
el número de pares crece cuadráticamente
es proporcional al cuadrado del número
de personas en el grupo
Lamentablemente nuestro cerebro son
notoriamente malos al captar
intuitivamente funciones no lineales por
eso parece improbable que 23 personas
puedan producir 253 pares posibles una
vez que los cerebros lo aceptan el
problema del cumpleaños tiene más
sentido los 253 pares tienen
probabilidad de coincidencia de
cumpleaños por la misma razón en un
grupo de 70 personas hay 2,415 pares
posibles y la probabilidad de que dos
personas tengan el mismo día de
cumpleaños es mayor al
99,9%. El problema del cumpleaños es un
ejemplo donde las matemáticas pueden
mostrar que cosas que parecen imposibles
como que la misma persona gane la
lotería dos veces en realidad no son
nada improbables a veces las
coincidencias no son tan coincidentes
como parecen
para ver más descubrimientos
sorprendentes vea con este video Qué tan
alto puede contar con sus dedos o
conozca esta historia de números
prohibidos
[Música]